STEVE BROWN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how on earth
did you narrow it down?
How did you pick what you
wanted to focus on?
Because there's a finite amount
of space to cram an
awful lot of stuff into.
STEVE BROWN: You mean the 60,000
stories of Burning Man?
And how do you find the right
stories for 90 minutes?
So we were looking for, I'd say,
a story arc that was very
similar across the board.
Which are people that, what they
took from Burning Man was
the catalyst or inspiration to
act on a dream, and set off on
a journey to do some big,
ambitious projects that they'd
never done before.
It's one of the more common
experiences of Burning Man.
And it's actually one of my
experiences from Burning Man
with this film.
This is the first time I've ever
produced a feature film.
And it was very much that
similar kind of a journey.
Burning Man is a community
that is sort of designed
intentionally to give people the
freedom and the permission
to act on their dreams.
And so there are a lot of
stories like that, start at
Burning Man.
So I was looking for, and our
team was looking for, stories
where we could follow somebody
who was acting on a dream.
Somebody like Katy, who didn't
used to be an artist, but she
went to Burning Man and decided
that that was what she
was going to be.
And we filmed her from
conception to realization of
her first art project.
Otto Von Danger, very different
side of Burning Man,
and kind of unexpected for
people to think it's just a
rave or it's some sort
of hippie thing.
But for him, this was the
first time he did a big,
meaningful project.
They were just really trying to
make a statement and make a
difference in the world.
And what he was actually trying
to do was trying to
create a statement that
was really uniting the
frustrations of both the Tea
Party and the Occupy movement.
And so it was a big,
ambitious project.
And Jon La Grace, not only was
he kind of on the front line
of this growth of Burning Man
becoming worldly, and people
with a lot of money showing up
and kind of paying for a
catered experience of Burning
Man, which was very
controversial.
He was from one of those camps,
a producer of one of
those camps.
But this was the year when he
was, when the whole camp was
really trying to give back and
really was trying to do
something new, which was host
Play)A(Skool, which was the
set for TEDxBlackRockCity.
Which is how I got connected
to them in the first place,
because I was the co-organizer
of that.
So we were looking for stories
that were somebody acting on a
dream, what happens next, and
kind of a cross-section of
different aspects of Burning
Man-- theme camps and kind of
the roughneck side of Burning
Man, and the art side of
Burning Man.
And then we got invited in to
film more and more of the
founders and inside
the organization.
And we realized their story
was the same thing.
The had big dreams.
And those dreams were also
getting very complicated as
they kind of collided with
reality in the year that
Burning Man hit limits
for the first time.
AUDIENCE: How did you ensure the
consent of everyone being
filmed, especially for the
rabbit popping out, where
people are riding on the ramp?
STEVE BROWN: So anyone we were
interviewing, we asked for
permission.
General crowd scenes in public
places, that's a little more
complicated.
But a crowd scene in a public
place where lots of people are
being filmed, that's
kind of fair game.
But anybody we interviewed, or
really kind of went in close
and told their story, we
asked for consent.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for making the film.
What didn't make it
into the film?
STEVE BROWN: What is that?
AUDIENCE: What didn't make
it into the film?
What scene, what aspects?
STEVE BROWN: Oh, so much.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE BROWN: Actually,
my background
is in tech and software.
And from my standpoint, some
of the most fascinating
stories of Burning Man are the
creativity and the innovation
that happens when it's not about
pleasing your venture
capitalists, or about money, or
sort of the Silicon Valley.
But it's just pure play and
innovation in this harsh
environment.
And you see that in art.
But you also see that
in technology.
And I mean, there was a project
just this last year
where people from
Ideate were--
you take off your clothes.
Go into a full-body scanner.
And then they would make
a 3D model of you.
And then they would attach a
little tracking device to you.
And then their radio-controlled
octocopter
would come and drop your clone
off somewhere in the playa.
That was sort of cool,
and fun, and
interesting, and playful.
But we just weren't there
filming that one.
But some that we did film
were more tech stories.
A couple years ago, you
go to Burning Man.
And you turn on your iPhone.
And you would say, gosh,
I didn't know
AT&T worked out here.
Well, it doesn't.
It was just some guys from the
OpenBTS project who were the
open source mobile phone sort
of operating system.
And they had a solar-powered
antenna.
And they were playing a cell
phone company out there, beta
testing really cool technology
about how do we create mobile
technology for people who
live on $1 a day.
For the liberation technologies
for poor
countries, and their beta
site is Burning Man.
And their next customers
are in Somalia.
Or who knows where they are.
So there were things like that
that were really interesting.
And they were just under the
same kind of story-- people
inspired to do something
creative, and original, and
ambitious in this environment.
And not doing it for money.
And not doing it for status.
And not doing it for fame.
But purely doing it as a
creative collaboration.
And there's a lot of
stuff like that.
Not all of it is simple enough
and visual enough to work in a
film like this.
I mean, we're back to
the last question.
There are 60,000 stories
out there.
You need to find stories that
are fairly simple, and fairly
visual, and can line up.
AUDIENCE: Obviously, you went
through and sort of talked a
lot about people's stories,
the struggles that
they had to get there.
I'm interested to know what
your struggle was
in making the film.
Like what were your kind
of highs and lows?
STEVE BROWN: So making
a film, I discovered,
is a lot like a--
well, it's just another
startup.
Which means you need to
have some crazy idea.
You need to convince some really
great people to join
and collaborate with you.
You need to raise the money.
You need to execute
like crazy.
And then at some point, you've
got to get distribution.
And it was kind of
the same thing.
And every one of those steps is
loaded with challenges just
like it is with a startup.
I think that the biggest
challenge in making a film
like this-- which is a story of
real people and real lives,
no actors, no script, but a
working hypothesis for where
the story is going and what's
going to happen next--
the biggest challenge is
actually being there when the
story is unfolding.
And there were stories that we
were following that kind of
went in a different direction or
just didn't really go where
we thought it was going to go.
And other ones really
kind of grew.
But if you're not there with the
camera rolling, it's like
it didn't happen.
So the biggest challenge is
actually being there when
things are happening.
And you saw so many
things in here.
You saw that we were actually
there in a lot of really
unique moments in the story,
both of those artists who were
trying to manifest their dream
and do something project, but
also of the Burning Man
organization and the founders.
So all these moments when their
dreams were colliding
with reality and getting very
complicated, we were in there,
in those meetings.
I mean, actually, I wasn't
And my co-director,
Jessie Deeter,
wasn't in those meetings.
But our camera and sound people
were in the meetings.
And they were like, you can't
come to this meeting.
This is a private meeting.
But we're going to let your
cameras be in here.
It was a really strange thing.
So we were there at these
moments when they were arguing
kind of fundamental questions
of their principles.
They had this sort of collision
of principles
between this openness that
allowed people to truly be
free versus now, what do they do
when it's sold out and too
many people want to go.
And it was really--
I mean, everybody around the
world thought, whoa.
They didn't know what
was going on.
But when you saw the footage
inside the board room, you see
they're having really heartfelt
debates about
principles and values.
And that was a big surprise.
And it was really amazing
to witness that.
But that was very lucky that we
were there with the cameras
rolling when all that
was going down.
AUDIENCE: What was
the funding?
How did you raise the funding?
And who provided the funding?
And what was the budget
for this movie?
STEVE BROWN: Well,
you saw the whole
last part of the credits.
And there are actually some
people from the early days of
Google on that list.
I did most of the fundraising.
And I asked a lot of people,
told people about the project.
And I explained the vision of
what we're trying to do in the
story, and why I thought it was
a story that was much more
relevant than just a
Burning Man story.
It was a very universal story.
And some people backed it.
For the talk, I'm not going
to put a number
on the actual budget.
But if you look at--
I mean, we were 13 months in
production of filming.
And all those shoots had a
director of photography and a
sound engineer.
Had a producer, associate
producer there helping
organize it all.
And you have hundreds of hours
of footage and then 100 more
hours of archival footage
from the old days.
And then there was a lot of time
spent with our amazing
editor, Andy Gersh, editing that
down to the 90 minutes
that you saw.
And then there's an amazing
soundtrack for the movie.
And even though most of the
artists on the soundtrack have
been inspired by Burning Man,
or have some connection to
Burning Man, and did some
amazing original music for the
film, they also have labels,
and managers, and agents.
So all that costs
a lot of money.
So it was a pretty big,
ambitious project for a
documentary.
AUDIENCE: What were you doing
just before you started this?
And how did you decide
to actually get
started on this project?
It was so big.
STEVE BROWN: So I've been
involved in a number of
startups, usually software.
And kind of every time, it's
been kind of this similar
drill of you have a vision which
is to solve some problem
that's going to change
the world.
And you raise money.
And you start to execute
on that vision.
And you get more, and more,
and more focused on a very
specific thing to
make that work.
And I found it kind of
starting to be more
constraining.
And I was looking for
a creative canvas
that was more open.
And film is a very wide
open and very
human creative canvas.
So I was really interested in
getting involved with that.
And so when we sort of stumbled
across a story that
looked really relevant
and interesting,
things kind of unfolded.
You go to Burning Man.
And you say, gosh, I've always
wanted to make a film.
And all of a sudden, you're
surrounded by people that say,
how can I help?
And so that stuff starts
to become real.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering.
How did you recruit people to be
the subjects of your film?
STEVE BROWN: So you sort of
start with what you know.
But we were also seeking out
a kind of a story which
resembled really kind of our own
story with the project--
people that were acting
on a dream, setting
off on some big project.
And we also had to go with where
people were accessible.
There were probably some amazing
projects where people
in Europe were building
something to
bring to Burning Man.
And it was the same story.
But we weren't over there.
We were here.
So our subjects were a little
closer to home--
the ones that we were able to
film all the way through were
a little closer to home.
But we discovered Katy.
We were filming a number
of people.
And actually, I remember I
showed some of our footage,
some selects of some of the
people we were starting to
develop character sketches of.
I showed it to my daughter.
And she said, Dad, this is a
very important story about
creativity, and being free, and
being able to be creative,
and following your passion.
That's a very important story
for young people, too.
So it shouldn't just be a bunch
of old people having a
midlife crisis.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE BROWN: And then
I went back.
And I looked at the people.
And I realized, you know what?
We need to keep looking.
And so we were looking.
And then we went to film Marco
Cochrane, who is an artist,
amazing artist, who does these
huge sculptures of Burning
Man-- "Bliss Dance" and "Truth
is Beauty." And he's been out
doing that for 20 years.
And so that's really
interesting.
But there wasn't a
story unfolding.
Because it was just similar
to what he's been
doing for a long time.
But right behind him, working,
welding on one of the
sculptures, was Katy.
And so we went there
interviewing
Marco, to talk to Marco.
And then we said, well,
who's that?
Who's that on your team?
And it turned out she
was right at the
beginning of that story.
So we were looking for
that kind of story.
And we wanted to find a story
where it was connected to the
great art of Burning Man.
And she was there.
Well, Otto Von Danger, this
one's my son's fault.
So he said, Dad, this is not
going to be a good movie
unless there's somebody that's
a little bit crazy.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE BROWN: Anyway, so we
actually went up to the playa
on July 4, 2012.
And we actually thought
we might be shooting
the end of the movie.
Because we thought Burning
Man might not happen.
Or it might never be the same.
It might not come
back together.
Because a lot of the big
projects were not able to--
their crew couldn't
get tickets.
And everyone was mad
at Burning Man.
And so no one could
raise money.
And so everything sort of felt
like it was falling apart.
So we went up there
for July 4.
Where it's kind of like the old
days-- no organization, no
fence, no tickets.
And that's where I met
Otto Von Danger.
And he had some crazy project
he was doing out there where
they were exploding things,
and blowing things up, and
shooting lots of guns.
And I asked my son.
He was with me.
And he says, well,
how about Otto?
And he said, I think he'll do.
And he was a wonderful story.
He was a wonderful character.
And he really embodied a number
of things, but just
this passion and commitment in
this campus of Burning Man
that allows people to do huge,
ambitious things that you
wouldn't expect them
to be able to do.
Otto Von Danger is living
on disability.
He's an injured Marine.
And he's having a hard
time getting by.
And then at Burning Man, he's
working on a massive,
super-challenging, super
roller coaster,
big, ambitious project.
And to me, that kind
of story where--
I mean, Katy was a nanny, and
Otto is a disabled veteran,
and Jon La Grace, somebody who
lost everything, they're not
like the Google founders.
They're not like the famous
people who are
out at Burning Man.
They're very ordinary people
with actually a lot stacked
against them.
But you kind of flip
the values.
And in this environment,
they shine.
And they rise.
And they're the heroes.
And I thought those were the
kind of people that, one, we
were looking for.
But two, they were also
more accessible.
They were open to us following
them around for a year.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
I was sort of struck by the
fact that everybody went
through this intense process
of very systematically
building and working in
sort of structured--
even though it was
a little crazy--
process.
And then they got to have their
moment of release at
Burning Man where their project
all came to an end,
and they saw the results.
You were still in the middle of
your process at that point.
Can you talk about that a
little bit and how your
experience was?
STEVE BROWN: Yeah.
We're still in the middle
the process.
Because we're just now launching
the film in theaters
and on demand just
this weekend.
So, yeah, but kind of like the
people in the film, it is sort
of a never-ending process.
The interesting thing--
so two kinds of projects
were in the film.
There were the ones
that burned down.
And that creates a space to
do something totally new.
And then there are other ones
where, like Katy, is heart.
She didn't burn that down.
It comes back down the hill.
It's in a warehouse.
She's trying to figure out
what to do with it.
Should I do another Kickstarter
to add some more
bells and whistles to it and
bring it back to Burning Man?
Or what should I do
with this thing?
And I think that one of things
that is unique about Burning
Man as an entire city but also
a lot of the art projects is
that kind of creative
destruction.
It goes back to the dust so
people can start over.
And this film is almost
to the point where
it really is launched.
And then it's wide open space.
And then I--
everybody in film
is like this.
Then you can kind of take a
breath and say, what's next?
It's what's unique about film is
that you have this intense
effort on a project.
And it has an end.
A company goes on.
Well, maybe it has an end
when Google buys it.
But maybe it goes
on indefinitely.
But films, like a lot of
these art projects,
they have an end.
And then that creates a space
for something new.
That's what I like about film.
AUDIENCE: I thought there was
an interesting kind of a
conflict of ideas between Larry
Harvey and John Law.
And the presentation of Law
towards the end of the
movie, where he--
you're showing his image and
talking about the org of
turning into a nonprofit.
And I kind of wonder if he gave
you any kind of a take on
what he thinks about that
or how that affects him.
STEVE BROWN: I did sit
with John Law.
Sat next to John Law and watched
the film with him when
we played in Sacramento.
And I said, John, I'm going to
sit next to you in case you
need to kick me.
Because I didn't know before
he saw the film what he'd
think of it.
But I mean, he was a really
interesting, important
character in the film.
Because there you saw this
original rift, this original
collision of values.
I mean, the original dream
was one about this
sort of pure freedom.
And then at some point,
it got out of control.
People actually got killed
up there in 1996.
And it really was
out of control.
So they had to decide.
This sort of, almost this
Utopian anarchist ideal of
freedom wasn't going
to work anymore.
So what are they going to do?
Is it going to just go away?
Or are they going
to reinvent it?
And John Law didn't want
the reinvention.
It was form an LLC.
Form a company.
Sell tickets.
Put up a fence.
Create a container for it.
Buy insurance.
He didn't want to
be part of that.
He wanted to stick to the
original dream and the
original value.
So there was a big
parting of ways.
And then when we were filming
this in 2011, 2012, we were
sort of hitting the next big
inflection point where again,
it was a collision of values.
I mean, that was the core
of what was happening.
They have values that were
really interesting.
And that they'd sort of gone
from pure self-expression and
freedom to a combination of
values of self-expression and
values of community.
And can we create a community
that allows people to truly be
themselves?
And that idea was working,
amazingly, for many, many
years until they hit limits,
until there wasn't
enough to go around.
And then the question is who
gets to decide who gets to be
part of this.
If somebody stands there as
the judge, decides who's
worthy of being part of it, then
the whole idea that you
truly have that freedom
kind of gets eroded.
Because now, I'm trying
to prove myself.
I'm trying to prove
I'm good enough.
Or at least I have
that feeling.
Or there's even a hint
of that feeling.
And so that's why they
did the lottery.
Because they didn't want
to be the judge.
And then that was a catastrophe
because it
destroyed community.
So all along it had
been this really
interesting debate of values.
Sort of like the Western
culture requirement in
freshman year at Stanford where
philosophers from kind
of thousands of years ago all
the way through the present
are sort of having these
fundamental arguments about
freedom versus order.
And how do we create a society
that allows people to be free.
But you need some structure.
You need some governance.
Otherwise, freedom goes away.
These kind of debates were all
playing out real time.
So the John Law rift was a very
early one about order
versus freedom.
And then they reinvented
themselves.
And then they had this
new collision.
But the resolution of the new
collision of values seemed to
be, when we were filming it,
that may be there would be a
new transformation.
And what really ticked off
John Law was sort of the
becoming this company.
Maybe that was going
to go away.
Maybe there was going
to be some new form.
And maybe that rift would
possibly even heal.
There was sort of hope.
I heard that a number of times
in people we talked to.
There was a hope that that rift
might somehow heal in
whatever came next.
And we don't know whether or not
that's going to happen or
where that's going to end.
But we have seen that this idea
of a community of people
that really allow each other
to be themselves in the
context of collaborating on art,
that that's happening a
lot of places, not just
at Burning Man.
We showed this in
Washington, DC.
And I had people in the audience
say, I've been to
three burns, but I've never
been to the playa.
So I mean, it's sort of
happening on the east coast.
Who would have thought that
that would be happening in
Washington, DC?
And then you saw at
the end where it's
happening around the world.
So there's an idea that maybe
some of those original values
that John Law was involved with,
maybe those are coming
back in sort of the new form of
Burning Man, which is not
sort of contained
to the playa.
So at the end, we were kind
of raising that question.
But the verdict is not in yet.
That story is just beginning.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you
so much for coming.
This was excellent.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]